let me give you some advice you can't
care about anyone else everyone else is
an
obstacle you care what an obstacle wants
or feels you're dead
if i'd cared about anyone or thing i
might have died
you have the talent whether you have the
killer
instinct is the big question
she thought she owned everyone that's
foolish unhinged
well you're fired why are you speaking
i think you licked me but there's
something about poetic justice that's
just
so poetic you won't admit you
love me and so
how do you feel to know
you always tell me get her
this doesn't have to be a scene it
really really does
i'd like to remind you all that i'm
doing this in heels
what was your name cruella if you can
i want to make trouble you in i do love
you trouble a bit of an extreme side yes
darling
what fun that is
she stole my dogs
i guess you must hate her she has made
it me or her
and i choose me
don't worry there's lots more bad things
coming perhaps
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perhaps
a bomb i think
i don't know why he came all the way up
here
there's nothing left
there are people out there
people worth saving
most people had finally given up hope
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
hey you okay there
jesus i think i hurt someone
this is ed warren here with lorraine all
right let's get started
residents of brookfield were shocked
this afternoon by the broad daylight
murder of bruno sauls
the court accepts the existence of god
every time a witness swears to tell the
truth
i think it's about time they accept the
existence of the devil
whatever is going on whatever happened
that day that was not marnie
it's a witch's totem we think your
family was
cursed and that connection is still
open
i'm only interested in reality
but i can see things that your people
can't
[Music]
something terrible happened here
master satanist is not an adversary to
be taken likely
she's reaching out to the darkness
lorraine you need to come back
you're saving him worth everything you
have
because that's what maybe all costs
the right
[Music]
let me just listen to my block
[Music]
without bumping into someone's
[Music]
cause you can see a future that i can't
know you are gonna change the world
[Music]
i just want to see the whole world
[Music]
tell the world we are not invisible
[Applause]
let's go
there's something on your shirt
[Music]
we are powerful
[Applause]
[Music]
in theaters and on hbo max june 11th
[Music]
you're gonna tell us everything you know
i'm not telling you a mother
you can electrocute him all day it'll
only make him angrier
i on the other hand will tell you
everything really
michael bryce was trying to put his past
behind him you need to forget
bodyguarding repeat after me
no bodyguarding no
rory carting then he got pulled
back in let go jesus to protect this
homicidal nut bags
wife what is he doing here i said get
anyone but
michael bryce i believe it's pronounced
thank you in four days
all of you loved was burned they're
planning a full-scale cyber attack do
not
screw this up but we are definitely
gonna screw this up
i promised my therapist no bodyguarding
let's not do that guys let's just focus
on i got it
no it's fine you guys just you guys have
had him maybe feather the break a bit
i need you to protect us good time to
have a baby
we gotta have mercy on ourselves now
repeat after me
i'm unlicensed i'm unlicensed that's
terrible
louder i'm unlicensed and i don't give
up
we need guns we need boats
we need them are you ready to get your
freak on
what that came out wrong not together
with us that also came out wrong
now let's go do what we do and blow some
things up
i would make a great mother don't you
think i think you're glad
thank you it must be your powerful
asexuality that makes you such a good
listener
we just acknowledge that not only are we
safe this really feels like a newbie
peter where is peter peter pizza peter
rabbit i'm starting to get worried
did you miss me wake up kid we have a
job to do
i'm running there tomorrow for cardio
day you can use your front legs too
let's have some fun
oh no you know what happens after you
eat too much sugar
that do you have any friends back home
can they be trusted
there's a couple i wouldn't let house
sit
[Music]
this is crazy
[Music]
the world has the way of changing
[Music]
[Music]
but we always come back together
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not going to think
about the submarine
[Music]
and now we got cars flying in the air
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
that's a long time dumb little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family
but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
[Music]
are you ready whatever's on you is you
are ready ready he's got his own private
army we need help
no way
so how do you all want to play this fast
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
[Music]
better
crank it all the way up get back we're
the soldiers
it's good to be back no white flag
we supposed to stop that hold on
i spent my entire life in your shadow
and now
you spend the rest of yours
living in mine
not today
really duct tape you acting like we on
our way to home depot
i don't wanna die
hey last month i went dancing at this
cute spot in florida
where my roommate's girl made like five
g's a night
[Music]
we just met yesterday and you're already
trying to take whole trips together
be ready by two hi
you wanna hear a story about how me and
this [ __ ] fell out it's kind of long
but it's felicia's face
you wanna go somewhere with me that's my
face
dear heavenly father we are asking you a
special prayer today
we asking you to send us [ __ ]
then thus
[Music]
watch every move this [ __ ] make
[Applause]
a real nice spot this is messy
you are messy your brain is broke
is this what you came here for do it
look like i came for this
i don't [ __ ] with you no more i didn't
do nothing wrong
i came to dance no no no no we're done
with that
why are you on my twitter why are you on
my facebook why are you on my tumblr why
are you dming me
sis why are you tagging me in photos you
don't even [ __ ] with me let me
know let me know yes it is
[Music]
the annual purge will conclude in three
two one
[Music]
thank you for your participation
we survived all police and emergency
services
have been reinstated all crime including
murder
is now illegal come on let's get to work
one night only rest of the year is
peaceful
help me help me
the purge is over please
no it ain't this is insane nobody hear
the sirens
there's no crime anymore anything goes
you rich can't hide behind your steel
walls no more
powerless how does that feel is the real
purge the forever purge
hurry up they're coming
come on follow me there's nowhere safe
to go
no way to get help oh my god
we gotta find another way to get out of
here
[Music]
this country's gonna collapse
mexico is opening its borders for the
next six hours
we're in this together
uh
does this translate
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i mean mistakes choosing
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
[Music]
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world i'm sorry
we had our orders and we played our
it was real to me
to me you were everything
[Music]
oh
[Music]
one thing's for sure
i'm done running from my past
[Music]
basketball camp is next weekend you got
amazing potential on the court
and i can help you get there that's not
what i want dad
you never let me do what i want to do
you never let me just
do me hold up wrong floor
that will smith i gotta deal with this
what in the matrix hello
[Music]
welcome king james i am the king of this
domain
this is the server-verse what'd you do
to my son where's dom
the only way you're getting your son
back is if you and i play a little
basketball
pete send this clown to the rejects what
is this
i'm a cartoon what's up doc
i need to assemble an elite team to help
get my son back i know what you're
looking for
a dream team ma'am shoot the ball
let's try that again shall we
king james
welcome to
[Music]
the space jam
[Music]
introducing you gotta win this game
let's end this and get our son
back
yikes
classic welcome to the space channel
[Music]
i'm going old school on his butt
[Applause]
this beach it's beautiful my swimsuit is
hurting
they do look small come on let's play
hide and seek
have you seen my children mom i'm right
here
he was six years old this morning
oh no mom i'm scared
there's something wrong with this beach
we were chosen for a reason
what's happening i don't know i can't
think
owned only in theaters this summer
[Music]
here's to hotel transylvania
johnny works so hard to make this extra
special
thank you dear son-in-law
i ruined everything johnny what are you
talking about
your dad never really thought of me as
part of the family all because i'm not a
monster
so you want to become a monster huh van
helsing
the muncification ray turns humans into
monsters and monsters into humans but is
this safe though
great question
that's weird nothing happened
[Music]
the nightmare it's over i'm human again
hey jack what's up johnny
oh no oh
frag look at you now look at me oh no no
he can't be you're human and i'm a
monster
it's like freaky friday but on a tuesday
though
what's going on
what's up fellas frank oh i'm balding
[Applause]
[Music]
every warrior has a beginning
i'm on a new level for 600 years
our ninja
the journey from here
is yours to decide
[Music]
but that is just the beginning i'm on a
new level
[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers
and the arrowhead is the key to
unlocking it
hello uh just wanted you to know this
has been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruises you could take
in the amazon this one is undoubtedly
the cheapest but also the most thrilling
heads up coming through
look out
marauders
natives
ladies and gentlemen the moment you've
all been waiting for
the backside of water
stays wonder of the world
we're headed up river to la grimas de
cristal when we secure our travel come
on
hello not a good time my brother and i
are looking for passage upriver
please go away i have a lot of money
if you believe in legends you should
believe in curses too
you're gonna beg me to turn back well i
look forward to disappointing you
ten thousand to bring you there alive
dead it's fifteen thousand why should i
pay more dead
dead i'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady
here we go
[Music]
oh god sorry frank sorry strong form
i cannot win you booked the river cruise
and you can't swim
the price just went up
super villains
[Music]
sad souls and costumes wanting you to
think they're all
dark and deep what's the like
living life as a punchline
[Music]
but all overtake would be one blessed
act of rebellion
for you to restore your dignity in its
entirety
you know the deal complete the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
love them or hate them these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few
days
any questions and yes
that is your hand very good
all gonna die i hope so
oh for god's sake
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
left like a bloodbath to start the day
they call you peacemaker
i cherish peace with all my heart i
don't care how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it
i thought you were the crazy one oh yeah
here's the deal we failed a mission you
died if we find out any information you
give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no
good morning goldie my name is guy and i
live
in free city i have everything i need
except one thing hey
excuse me
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what
the stuff we do day after day literally
not once
today's gonna be different goldie what
are we looking at
who are you we ran into each other the
other day how did you find me i waited
outside by the murder train guy
i have to tell you something there is no
easy way to say this this world
it's a video game
i really want to kiss you is that weird
listen to me you're not real
[Music]
wait you let who kiss you guy there's
not a button for that
oh he found the button
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time now if that's not real
i don't know what it is millie i know
this world
is just a game but this place these
people that's all i have
thanks guys who is this guy this
character
in the video game free city has been
turning heads
by being the good guy who is blue shirt
guy
you're absolutely right who is he or she
indeed this loser is ruining the game
man
i don't care if he's arnold frickin
schwarzenberger
terminate him
we're doing great guy in two days the
game is gonna shut down
you this whole city they'll be gone
what if we can save it
[Music]
was that cool it felt really cool we
could change
our world but we have to fight together
i don't even know what's happening right
now
but i love it this is the first time
i've ever driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
thank you watch out for this
they seem nice
you know i
how many albums have you had four
and no hits honey find the songs that
move you
until you do that you ain't going
nowhere
you do talk don't you not just sing i'd
like you to call me miss franklin
[Music]
you have to disturb the peace when you
can't get no peace
candy man the urban legend is if you say
his name
five times while looking in the mirror
he appears in the reflection
and kills you who would do that
well we're still alive
let's go
trina you broke the door
this isn't funny
[Music]
i feel really connected to this
neighborhood
cabrini green it was the projects
yeah i just moved in around the corner
the old candy factory i'm an artist
you looking for candy man
he's the monster that's part of this
neighborhood
why are you drawn to this i'm hoping to
spread the story all about candyman the
mirror
invites you to summon him
you should say his name i dare you
candyman
candyman candyman candyman
don't say that candy man
[Music]
i think i made a mistake
i brought him back candyman isn't real
something's happening to me
[Music]
he had a purpose for you to be another
one of his terrible stories
i guess he found
the writing me the walls the sweet smell
of blood
be my
it's victim real candy man
[Music]
you